gomez - welcome back to some all day
Celes iron king well I heard the stories
they say you're a butt plug again oh
that's fine I needed to shave my
eyebrows anyway it's not even hard I
understand really parents is that really
how you feel
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] why do you whine hide your [ __ ]
lightning sword now you go into the
bench oh my god I have so many souls
[Music]
don't be a bus don't be a vice hey I'm
gonna teleport all right let's do that
again
why come off why stop hey man thanks for
killing me back there appreciate it Oh
God
Oh God that's way too close to your
jungle backup thank you
damn I'm alive I'm alive apple juice
apple juice apple juice man what kind of
sick [ __ ] pervert deny somebody's
apple juice what what no one stuck
no you know what I'm switching this
[ __ ] up I got a I got a bad you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Ebanks on her Pam had a lamb any no
no not again please
please don't harm me I'm a dad come
please
that's okay oh great
it's so [ __ ] hard BAM oh good
bring it Brittany
bring it gosh ex brought it alright you
little [ __ ]
I may have died from smelter Garman [ __ ]
god dammit I don't know how to PvP Oh
what the [ __ ] am i doing oh god what is
that
what you doing oh oh oh it's ash making
tan [ __ ] okay oh [ __ ]
I'm so dead oh no come here
little [ __ ]
oh well thanks today
[Music]
I hate when he goes into that don't know
no no no no touch me oh god oh I could
actually do it I have a lot of esters
I can't believe I [ __ ] don't know how
to [ __ ] dodge his moveset by now you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll slap your
ass all day if I have okay I'll not obey
that's that second Oh God look at my
[ __ ] health
oh god if I get a hit I die Oh what am i
doing come on maybe it's [ __ ] easy
slap that ass like it jiggles like a
[ __ ] nope not today you little [ __ ]
that's right I said it
apple juice my apple juice best apple
juice [ __ ]
come on
, give me that sweet ass oh-oh-oh-oh
what's the champion always a champion
[Music]
let's see what amazing a word we get Oh
a bonfire a great bonfire check Ponte
it's good I have a new skirt it's Marc
Jacobs at least I got my hammer now come
here sit the [ __ ] down [ __ ] sit the
[ __ ] down take a seat take a seat ride
eh oh great this looks fun like this
that's what I needed thank you it has to
be a boss fight here I can smell his
butt cheeks they are ready to get
slapped all right what do we got
that's nice all afternoon math that's
lovely I do myself though sometimes it's
no [ __ ] way in a million days that I
would be able to kill that I have one
but slammer that's it
you got [ __ ] magma abs [ __ ] that I'm
out of here please
Oh goddamn it hi all this
alright I'll slap your face I guess oh
Jesus he had lasers and [ __ ] don't you
laser for us it's not good for the
environment
oh god what have you that go [ __ ] almost
dad come on Oh
Oh slap that batch what is a batch I
don't know but he's dead I think yeah oh
my god two bosses oh my gosh oh my gosh
alright where did we go next adventure
excuse me could you get the [ __ ] out of
the way oh I'd kill ya I did it way
better now what the watch where the [ __ ]
did you guys come from help
why is she doing anything you know what
stop have a can she's just standing
there what a batch all right I got my
Marc Jacobs skirt I'm ready to go into
Silent Hill apparently mom mom are you
there this is actually pretty [ __ ]
creepy here we go alright I made it
what's up fatty this must be a boss
there's nothing here
it must be a crap escape oh god yeah so
what the [ __ ] are you doing sit the [ __ ]
down
[ __ ] that's right she has two butts oh
my god that's usually a good thing you
know what I'm [ __ ] out of here [ __ ]
Oh No alright I guess I'll stay then so
[ __ ] disgusting I don't care about
Glee analysis if there's an ass I'm here
to slap it that's right seriously what
alright that's fine I don't mind
hey I'll have another one oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
come on No
all right we should be able to take her
down I'm pretty sure actually Oh
missed me oh she's stuck Hey look at
that [ __ ] damage this hammer is so
obese seriously oh oh she's done [ __ ] no
I don't like it no wait maybe I should
all right I'm the best
nah it's the hammer of Justice the
hammer of jingle but what if I told you
company of champion is easy
[Music]
that was goddamn beautiful all of my
fields I don't my legs
[Music]